hello people of the internet it has been
quite a while and look you know i'll be
honest with you it's been a bit dry
lately i haven't been booking [ __ ]
casting directors i'm not saying it's on
you but if you see me out in these
streets selling ass for loose pocket
change
hey all right don't ever say david sews
above a job you know get on these
screens and put these lips to work
now i don't like these jokes they hurt
you know for those of you out there who
do not act or have never auditioned
before and there's been a lot of
questions about what the process is like
auditioning is like you know
hot swamp ass it sucks even when 99 of
auditions now are self taped at home it
just it's hard because you're sitting at
home you're second guessing all your
choices and the moment that you click
[ __ ] scent
[Music]
well i do this to myself huh why i do
this i love youtube but you know
sometimes the challenge is great guys
and with the whole auditioning thing i
get it i understand i'm not really
putting myself out there 100 if anything
else you know hollywood might be getting
like 15
of what i can do because i've spread my
time up with so many different projects
specifically passion projects that i
really really enjoy so you know you miss
all the shots you don't take right you
fish without if an eagle comes and it
lands in your mouth what chicken
what do you want from me but my main
focus right now especially for this year
is building up this matcha store junebe
me and joe
and greg our buddy greg we're going to
open up a matcha store out in hawaii
oahu waikiki specifically junebe matcha
it's one of those passion projects we've
been working on for like a year and a
half jimmy matcha to me is more than
just like a passion project it's really
kind of carving a big chunk in space out
of my legacy and you know when i say
things like legacy i know a lot of
people are like oh what does that mean
bro what do you mean legacy hey listen
this right here
that's my nut sack suck it everything
nowadays even from your favorite
creators is all about a paycheck which
is not a bad thing but because i've
never chased a paycheck and i've always
chased like this idea of being able to
create and live life the way that i want
to money is a hard
factor of motivation for me it doesn't
really get me up and going i need money
like i just said your boy about the
junebe matcha is
you know it's a way for us to make high
quality matcha accessible to people
that's essentially what the brand is
about fun drinks but the quality that
you get out of the stuff is great and
the same thing with secret society this
is the other passion project that i have
by the way what you think about the
spring line shirts baby we going vintage
hues ew
check out the shorts
you like that you like them cakes [ __ ]
and listen it hasn't been completely dry
in the last couple years i got to do an
indie film
sitting in a regular ass chair
oh you know i'm just feeling generous
today gentlemen that's it
why the payday
loan what they they called you asked us
a bunch of weird questions too like the
champion nipples i said africa i kept it
real safe i got to fulfill my dream of
being on a cooking show that got picked
up on netflix it would be fabulous it'll
be delicious and a little awkward
and i'm doing a podcast with the homie
tim dude's behind the foods baby it's
all good so i'm definitely counting my
blessings i'm just trying to figure out
right now in the acting world every time
i go for a roll for a loud fat asian guy
who the [ __ ] is taking my roles what
what other
who who's louder and fatter and more
asian than me who who's taking my gut
who who scarlett johansson you sexy
asian [ __ ] one of the worst feelings on
earth is when you have this role that
you really [ __ ] like you kill the
audition you get call backs the role is
for somebody between the age of 30 to 35
they're korean they're six feet tall
they they love matcha and then you find
out your role is taken by
scarlett johansson you sexy asians what
the hell do you want from me huh that's
that's that's about it well guess what i
just have to get to work you
[ __ ] wait till i get into
acting dude when i'm 100 i'm snatching
up all your rolls there's going to be a
roll for a blonde blue-eyed
fat ass white girl and i'm
taking it but anyways let's get this day
started uh i'm going to take you guys
quickly to one of my favorite coffee
shops in la great
okay so
i know i said i was going to go get
coffee
but i'm not okay we'll we'll show you
the the favorite copy spot next time i
actually forgot i have an order to pick
up so today is a very very special
special day my friends i am picking up a
whole
smoked yellow tail from adam perry lane
now if you don't know who adam perry
lang is i've talked about him multiple
times on the podcast if you've you know
if you're following my instagram you'll
see that i've posted his lovely lovely
barbecue he is probably
i say to me he's more than just a chef
he's somebody who actually inspires me
and everybody who has gone to adam perry
lane that has seen my stories or have
heard me talk about him i'm pretty sure
none of you have been disappointed and
listen let me tell you something your
boy
[Laughter]
has a book
[Music]
uh chef you're moving you're not going
to be at the pasadena spot anymore sadly
no i love these pasadena it's been
fantastic for me but we're going to be
moving to torrance so we're going to the
strand brewery it's off of domingo
street i don't know the exact address
but i'll be posting on my instagram adam
perry lang and um
yeah we're really excited i'm actually
it's going to be 2.0 because i'm
bringing my tractor trailer barbecue i
have all these fire pits coming and it's
gonna be
it's gonna be mega you know we've
actually known each other for quite a
while now you're dming each other every
now and then but like i said every time
you cook anything that you open up i'm
always there like i really do appreciate
specifically all like the effort and
time that you put into your food i think
food has become really popular but i
think a lot of the times people are
forgetting about the craft i appreciate
i mean for me having you and i mean you
are someone who truly appreciates fine
food hey take care bud
you are someone who really truly
appreciates fine food and you know for
me feeding you you have so much
appreciation for it i mean you are like
you're like perfect you like the reason
why i like to cook i like to share i
like to give and you know put my effort
into it so so well chef thank you so
much thanks my mom i can't wait to see
in torrance we are going to try
the
hamachi
[Music]
right here
oh that's so good
that is so good
listen
i'm just going to end the video here if
you guys are going to be out in torrance
the dates will be there he's moving over
to torrance
and he's going to be there for three
months with the brewery check it out
i'll see y'all next time but this right
here